lot to talk about a lot going on donald
trump leaving washington this week
now a majority of the country is happy
to see him leave
that is true the fact remains that we
did have a four-year relationship with
president trump
and we got to know the people in his
administration pretty well
and a lot of us want to know what's next
for people like melania
mike pence rudy giuliani what's going to
happen
well we happen to know what's next in
their stories
so here now are the end credits to the
trump administration
it has been the greatest honor of my
life to serve as first lady
of the united states
just a few short months ago we were
seeing the american dream become a
reality
[Music]
it is the first purely partisan
impeachment
he can't want them to be successful more
than they want to be successful
[Music]
10th mountain division train here deploy
here
climb to glory
[Music]
the notion that speaking english
wouldn't be a part of immigration
systems would be actually very
historical
[Music]
he had closed the gap in six weeks and
that was game on
are you a lawyer
america is great when we behave
greatly
you're mixing up and you're not staying
clear on the purpose of this program
[Music]
let's see if you can try thinking
rational
[Music]
yeah we love you roger
[Music]
god bless our president and god bless
the united states of america
[Music]
our press secretary gave alternative
facts to that
you